RACHEL O'MEARA: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming today.
I'm Rachel O'Meara, and I'm
here to introduce Mark McClusky
today.
We're very excited to host Mark
here at Google Mountain View.
Mark is the CEO of
wired.com, which a lot of you
are probably familiar
with, and also has
his first book out,
"Faster, Higher, Stronger."
So we're going to be
hearing Mark talk about all
of the prowess of athletes and
how technology and data help
people strive to
be better athletes.
Please welcome Mark.
Thank you.
MARK MCCLUSKY:
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me here.
This is exciting to
get to come to talk
to you all about this book that
I've spent so long working on.
The first question
almost everyone
asks me is like, why
did you write this book?
It's very interesting
that people always
want to understand
the reasons that you
come to a subject matter.
This is me at 17 looking really,
really gaunt as a cyclist.
That's Franklin Shop 'n Save.
That's Franklin, Pennsylvania.
That was the local
grocery store chain.
And I talked them into
sponsoring a cycling team.
They sort of really
didn't understand
what I meant by a cycling team.
But the investment was minimal,
and they were talked into it.
That's my best
friend growing up,
Mike Dittman, in
front of me there.
I talked him into racing bikes.
He had been a swimmer, But I'd
just started a cycling team.
I needed a team.
And so it seemed sensible that
there be more than one of me
on the team.
This is sort of the
first American bike boom.
Greg LeMond had just won
the Tour de France in 1986.
the John Tesh coverage on CBS
with, like, the weird synth
music that they'd play.
And I loved it.
I thought it was the
most amazing sport ever.
It really became a
huge part of my life.
And, you know, like most
young athletes, I had dreams.
I had dreams, someday I'll
ride in the Olympic Games.
Someday, I'll ride in
the Tour de France.
Right?
So you get all the
gear and the kit.
You grow the mullet,
because that was cool then.
Somebody should
have talked to me
about a lot of hair decisions.
This is outside a race
in Lordstown, Ohio.
And I finished second that day.
I still remember the
sprint I lost that race.
So I was good.
I wasn't great.
And I was a pretty big
fish in a very small pond,
American cycling.
Especially American cycling
in rural western Pennsylvania
in 1989 was not a
big pool of talent.
And so you didn't necessarily
have to be that great.
Got older.
Went to college.
Went to school in Minnesota.
The results started
to change for me.
I started getting killed.
And I did not handle that well.
It was really disappointing
to me to lose races the way
I was losing races.
My team, we qualified for
nationals our freshman year.
And we got destroyed there
by schools like schools
out here, where it was sunny
and they rode all year.
And we had been on
trainers all winter.
I had reached a plateau.
That wasn't the
progression that I
thought I would see from
the work I was getting.
I saw people around me
who were working much less
and who were just really
beating me very badly.
So I kind of gave it up.
I stopped riding.
I actually stopped riding for
about 10 years, pretty much
full stop, because
it had never been
a recreational activity for me.
It had always been a very
competitive activity.
I still dream to go
into the Olympics.
And I found a different
way to do that.
Still some bad hair
choices there on the left.
That's my credential for
the 1996 Olympics at SI.
You can't see the ponytail.
So I started my career
at "Sports Illustrated"
as a journalist and then have
been in Wired for nine years.
I've covered three Olympics,
tons of other high-end sporting
events.
And those questions really
still loomed in my mind.
What separates great
athletes from even very,
very good athletes?
What are those
distinctions that lead
to being on the top
of the Olympic podium?
And I've been lucky
enough, through my career,
to get to meet a lot
of those athletes
and coaches and scientists.
And that's really where
this book came from.
One place that my
career took me was
to London on August 5, 2012.
I'm going to play a quick video.
This is the 100 meter final.
One thing to watch here
is right before the final.
It's going to happen sort
of behind those purple lane
markers.
Somebody actually throws
a bottle from the stands
and tries to hit the runners
before the start of this race.
Thankfully, that didn't work.
But just something to watch.
But we're going to watch
this race real quick.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-On their way, and Gatlin
got away brilliantly.
And he's ahead at the moment.
Bolt going [INAUDIBLE].
Here comes Usain Bolt!
Usain Bolt storming
through, takes it again.
Blake gets the silver-- 9.64.
Oh, he's returned his title
in the most emphatic way.
Brilliant, brilliant, brilliant.
Usain Bolt of Jamaica is the
fastest man on the planet.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARK MCCLUSKY: So first of all,
let's talk about how awesome
that announcer is.
You know, "He's
retained his title
in the most emphatic way."
And at the end
says, "Usain Bolt is
the fastest man on the planet."
And that's the
title that we give
the person who wins
the Olympic 100 meters.
Incidentally, this was
my view of that moment.
They do move pretty fast.
You can see that my
camera couldn't quite
actually resolve the runners.
I actually love the sort
of abstract nature of this.
One other thing about it.
This is the fastest
100 meters ever run.
The first seven blurs there
finished under 10 seconds.
And that's Asafa
Powell in the back.
He pulled his
hamstring in the race,
and would have been
under 10 seconds.
And there's never been a
race with eight runners
under 10 seconds before.
Here's a slightly clearer view
of the finish of that race.
This is the photo finish shot.
So you think Usain Bolt's the
fastest man on the planet.
And when you watch that
video, it does look emphatic.
It looks like he's
destroyed these guys, right?
It's important to remember
how small the margins are
at the elite level.
Will Hopkins is a
sports scientist
in New Zealand who's done a lot
of work trying to understand
the individual variation
of athletes' performances.
Not the differences between
athletes, but the difference
in an athlete in
his performances.
And by crunching a lot of
numbers, Will's a statistician.
In short track and field events,
that variation is about 0.8
of a percent.
So I've drawn a quick bell
curve of a 0.8% on either side.
So if we just play with
a hypothetical here,
that means that Bolt could
have run as fast as 9:55,
which destroys his
own world record.
It's sort of an
otherworldly time.
You could imagine
him running as slowly
is 9:71, which is still
great and ekes out the win.
Blake ran a 9:82.
But of course, Bolt's
not the only one
who has that variation.
So you can start to move
all these guys around.
There's a scenario here,
with that variation,
at the same level of fitness,
the same sort of platonic state
that they were in,
where Yohan Blake wins
and Bolt and Gatlin
tie for the silver.
It's fun.
You can just really
start to mess with this.
You can actually come with a
three-way dead heat for gold
and Tyson Gay just
out of the medals.
It's just fun to
move these around.
You can have a
four-way tie for bronze
if you really want
to mess with it.
Now we're back to what
actually happened that day.
The point being that we
take these, in this case,
under 10 seconds,
and we think that is
the exact measurement
of the athlete.
And it is the exact measurement
of that athlete for those 10
seconds.
The next day, it's not the same.
An hour later, it's
maybe not the same.
There's so many factors
that play into performance
at this level.
So one of the ideas that I
really explore in the book
is how small those
margins are and what
it means to be playing at
that level with those margins.
I want to talk about
a few ideas that
sort of cut across the book.
The book's organized by things
like nutrition and recovery
and what is fatigue
and skill acquisition.
But then there are some sort
of themes that I think resonate
throughout the book.
And I want to talk about
those with you today.
This is the first one.
Lots of little things
become big changes.
Dave Brailsford here.
He took over British
Cycling about a decade ago.
British Cycling was
a laughingstock.
It was a terrible,
terrible program.
Between 1924 and 1988, they
did not win a single gold medal
at the Olympics or
World Championships.
They actually had won
two bronzes in that time
at the Olympics.
It was a mess.
It was France, Germany, Italy.
Even the US had started
to outperform the Brits
in cycling, and
especially track cycling.
And so they really started
to think about why that was.
And what did they need to
do to change their results?
And they came up with
a different approach.
And Brailsford described
it as performance
through the aggregation
of marginal gains.
What did he mean
by marginal gains?
We think of trying to
improve performance
as this idea of, like, we
find one big, awesome thing,
and suddenly we're 10%
better or 5% better.
Or at the elite level, even
2% better is a huge change.
I would argue that there
aren't many of those left,
especially at the elite level.
We're pretty good
at this stuff now.
We've only been doing it about
150 years, sort of sports
as we think of them.
But we've optimized
a lot of things,
and our understanding,
especially in the past 50
years, has really boomed.
It's really hard to
find a big thing.
There are a couple that
people have been playing with,
and I'll talk about
some of those.
What Brailsford and British
Cycling sort of theorized was,
OK.
Like, let's stop
looking for big things.
So instead of one thing
that'll get me 10%,
let me start to add up 10
things at a percent each,
or at a 0.10% each.
And when I stack these
on top of each other,
I start to get somewhere.
These improvements
sort of accrue
like interest in this scenario.
And those little
changes really add up.
So let me give you some
examples of what they did.
The first thing
they did was they
started to spend an immense
amount of time and energy
on their equipment.
The nickname they
gave themselves
was the Secret Squirrel Club.
We would call it a
Skunk Works, right.
But the British phrase
was Secret Squirrel Club.
Dimitris Katsanis was a Greek
competitive track cyclist
who then became a
composites engineer.
So he was uniquely sort of
qualified when they came to him
and said, build us the
fastest bike in the world.
And so he went and
spent a couple of years
and built-- this is the
Mark II of the track frame.
He built the Mark
I. His frames have
won over 50 gold medals at the
Olympic and World Championship
level.
They're incredibly
successful frames.
They're crazy, crazy light,
they are incredibly stiff,
and they are super aerodynamic.
You can see some of the
shaping on the tubes.
They would do a lot of work.
British Motorsport is a very
huge resource, especially
on the aerodynamic side.
All of the F1 constructors
live in Great Britain.
And so they did a lot of
work with the F1 people.
The handlebar there is
another thing they did.
You can see the
shaping there, again,
looking for aerodynamics.
They called it the cobra, is
what the riders called it.
One thing that's interesting
about track cycling now,
and this is something
caused by this crazy arms
race on equipment,
is the UCI, which
is the world governing
body for cycling.
They have to race on equipment
that can be purchased.
You can't make bespoke gear that
is unavailable to the public.
So it's really hard to
buy because they actually
don't want to sell it.
So it took me three emails
and a couple of phone
calls for them to send me--
this is from the brochure
that I finally extracted
from British Cycling.
I'm now going to put
up the prices for each
of these things.
So that's a 25,000
pound track frame.
So the frame's 25,000 pounds.
The bars are 23,000 pounds.
So you add it up.
That's 48,000, almost 49,000
pounds or approximately,
according to Google's
search engine, $78,000.
And that's for a
frame and stems.
No wheels, no equipment.
The helmet that they
use, they will sell you
for about 10,000 pounds.
It's incredibly expensive gear.
It's very successful
gear, and they
think it gives them a huge edge.
So that's one gain.
Anybody who's ever
slept in a hotel
has slept on a bad
pillow, and woken up
and their neck is killing them.
British cyclists travel
with their own pillows
for that reason and for
another reason, which
is the same reason that they're
incredibly obsessive hand
washers and frankly won't shake
your hand when they meet you.
Because you could be sick.
Or you could have seen
someone who was sick,
or you could have been
around someone who was sick,
or somebody who was sick could
have been in your hotel room.
7% of competitors at the London
Olympics in 2012 got sick.
And that sucks.
Getting sick during the Olympics
after a lifetime of training
is a terrible, terrible
thing to have happen to you.
So anything you can do
to ameliorate that risk
is hugely important.
Another trick in the British
Cycling arsenal, and not
just British cyclists,
is beet juice.
This is kind of the hottest
performance drink in athletics
right now.
Here's how it works.
So we all probably think
that nitrates and nitrates
are bad for us, because there
were studies done, usually
on processed meats, cured
meats, linking those
to possible higher
incidences of cancer.
First of all, those
studies are really iffy,
so I would suggest
you not worry about it
quite as much as perhaps you do.
But also, it turns
out that nitrates
have really interesting
effects on the bodies.
So beet juice is
very high in nitrate.
In the body, that's
turned into nitrite
and then into nitric oxide.
Nitric oxide in the
bloodstream does two things.
The first thing it
does is it actually
dilates the blood vessel.
The blood vessel
gets bigger, and that
means that more blood flows
through that blood vessel.
And that's good if you're
an endurance athlete
because you're getting
more blood to the muscle.
You can power your
efforts more effectively.
The other is-- and this
is even more crazy--
it seems to make
the mitochondria
inside of that muscle
more efficient.
So a two-for of I can get more
blood and oxygen to the muscle
and the mitochondria use it more
efficiently is really awesome.
That's sort of like, hurray.
This is not so marginal.
Right now, it looks
like about 3%,
and that's for efforts
between five and 30 minutes.
For shorter efforts, for
efforts less than five minutes,
this energy pathway
isn't really the energy
pathway that powers that
sort of muscular work.
For more than 30 minutes,
that research is ongoing.
It's a little iffier.
There's some studies
that seem pretty good.
There are some that
seem not so good.
But there is some hint that
even for longer efforts,
it has that benefit.
Ironically, it has more
benefit for people like me
or any other weekend
warriors in the room
than it does for elite athletes.
They've optimized some of
those pathways already.
They have incredibly
good capillary density
in their muscles.
So they're getting as much
blood as they possibly
can to their muscles.
I don't, because
I'm out of shape.
And so this seems to
work better, actually,
for sort of recreationally
active athletes
than elite athletes.
All that said, elite
athletes are using it
because there doesn't
seem to be any downside.
In fact, Andy Jones is
the researcher in the UK
who's done most of
the work on this.
His Twitter handle
is andybeetroot,
is how much he likes beet juice.
He was telling me that
during the London Olympics,
it was actually very hard
to buy beet juice in London
because all of the teams
were buying so much of it.
It does have one downside.
Mark Cavendish is
a world champion.
And the hashtag
#pissingrainbows never quite
took off as much
as you might think.
It was interesting when
you click on that hashtag
and see what else shows up.
Be ready for that.
Yeah.
If you're going to
drink a lot of beet
juice be ready, because
it will do things.
Track races take place at a
standing start, track cycling
races.
So you're held either by a coach
or sort of in a timing device
that sort of levers
the bike and lets
you go when the race starts.
So that traction in that
moment is really important.
They believe, British
Cycling believes,
that by wiping down the
tires with isopropyl alcohol,
getting them as
clean as possible--
and it actually leaves
them slightly tacky,
depending on the rubber
compound-- that they
get a little benefit
on that start.
It's maybe a
thousandth of a second,
but thousandths of
a second matter.
Like track races are won or lost
by a thousandth of a second.
One more here.
This is Laura Trott, a
Great Britain cyclist.
She's wearing hot
pants, which is
what they called these warm-up
pants that they developed
with Adidas and one of the
universities in the UK.
They do huge warm-up,
and then there's
a holding area where the
cyclists have to sit and wait
for their race, sometimes
up to 30 minutes.
When you actually do that,
your muscles start to cool off.
And part of the
point of the warm-up
is to have the muscles warm
because that helps blood flow.
These pants have
heating elements,
especially along the thighs
and the hamstrings, actually
at 107 degrees.
And so they would do their
warm-ups, they'd put them,
and they'd sit there in the
area, in the holding area,
with those on, peel them off,
get on the bike, do their race.
Ironically, or perhaps not
ironically but interestingly,
Australia showed up with
a very similar idea.
It was an idea
that everybody sort
of-- that at least
those two countries,
which are sort of neck
and neck in sports
science in a lot of ways--
came to at the same time.
The first study they published
is insane, the effectiveness.
They found a 9% improvement
in sprint performance
on athletes who wore these.
I'll be interested to
see if that's replicable,
because that's huge.
They aren't the most flattering
pant that was ever built.
Laura probably didn't mind.
This was after winning
her second gold medal.
I love this picture of
her mom, especially.
You add all of this up, and you
had an incredibly successful
program.
Of the 10 gold medals available
in track cycling in London,
the UK won seven of them.
And would have won an eighth
except they were disqualified
for crossing a line on the track
by about a centimeter, which
is not the sort of
mistake British cyclists
make very often, frankly.
To me, it just really
shows the power
of adding up those
small gains, especially
in an elite environment where
the margins are so small.
That if you really
interrogate every single thing
that you're doing, every
single part of your program,
and try and optimize every
vector of it, it's hard to do.
Right?
It's exhausting work
to think that way.
But it can have
pretty huge benefits.
The next idea I want to talk
about is this, n equals 1.
For the science
types in the room,
N is the size of the population
under study in an experiment.
Human beings are
incredibly individual.
Crazily, crazily individual.
And I say that, and
everybody's like, yeah, yeah.
We're individuals, right?
No, seriously.
We're like, really,
really, really individual.
So much of how we perform
in an athletic context
comes down to genetic factors.
It comes down to things that
are unique to each of us
as individuals, from nutrition
to motivation to how we respond
to training and
to our physiology,
to our morphology, the
size of our bodies.
And so I want to talk about
a couple of those things.
Wendy Fox is a designer in
Melbourne who did this project.
This is every female gold
medalist from London.
She sells this awesome poster.
I would need to order one.
She was kind enough to
let me use this material.
This is one of those
gold medalists, a rower.
Helen Glover had only
been rowing for four years
when she won this gold medal.
And you might say,
hey, but 10,000 hours.
OK, so I'm here to say that
10,000 hours isn't the be-all
and end-all because there are
things that sports require
of us that we may or may not
have innate abilities toward.
Helen had been a competitive
field hockey player in the UK
and a pretty good one.
In the UK, it's
the county level.
It's sort of like the
state level here in the US.
Not to the national or
international level.
And she sort of plateaued there.
UK sport had this program,
and I love the name of it.
They called it Sporting Giants.
And in 2007, they put out
a call for tall athletes,
because there are some
sports where being tall
is really, really important.
We all know basketball is
certainly one of those.
Volleyball is one of those.
Team handball, which is another
team sport in the Olympics,
is one of them.
Rowing is one of them.
Being tall in rowing, all
other things being equal,
is awesome because
it's a physics problem.
You have a longer lever,
basically, to move an oar.
So if you were a woman who
was taller than 5' 11",
you were asked to submit an
application to this program.
For the men, I
believe it was 6' 2".
You might not 5'
11" is that tall.
You sort of think, oh 5' 11"'s
tall, but not crazy tall.
Fewer than 3% of women on the
planet are taller than 5' 10".
In the US, it's 2.4.
In the UK, it's a
little less than that.
So 5' 10"'s pretty tall.
So fewer than 3% of women
were taller than 5' 10".
16 of the 17 Olympic rowing
gold medalists were 5'
10" or taller.
It's really helpful.
It's hard to compete
being shorter than that.
I did leave off the
coxswain, who is not.
So that's cheating, I
guess. it's 16 of the 18.
This is not an
average population.
This is actually
the average woman
in the United States,
is 5' 4" and 158 pounds.
And then you line her up against
a couple of gold medalists
that show the range here.
That's Gabby
Douglas, the gymnast,
who's 5 inches shorter
and weighs 70 pounds less.
Being small and light
as a gymnast or a diver,
again, a huge advantage.
You're rotating a mass.
You want something
short and light
because you can
rotate it faster.
You can complete more spins.
Sylvia Fowles is
13 inches taller
and weighs 43 pounds more.
Obviously, Sylvia
at 6' 5" is actually
the tallest gold
medalist in London.
That diversity of body type is
a relatively recent phenomenon
at the Olympic level.
David Epstein, who wrote a great
book called "The Sports Gene,"
referred to it as the
Big Bang of body types.
That there used to be a sort of
like generalized athlete body
type in the middle, and that
that's really sort of exploded
into this diversity
that you see.
There's no athlete
in the Olympic games
who's sort of average.
It just doesn't happen.
I don't have a name
for average woman USA.
I keep thinking it would be
great to give her a name.
And let's think about
actually 100 of her.
Because I want to talk
about another sort of factor
that leads into
elite performance,
and that's your
response to training.
This is Claude Bouchard.
Claude is a researcher who
grew up in Quebec City.
Tell me if this story sounds
familiar from the start.
He was a hockey player.
He was pretty good.
Then he stopped growing.
Other guys got bigger.
And he wasn't able
to compete anymore.
And when you talk
to him about it,
he's like, I just didn't
know what was happening.
I didn't know why I
couldn't get bigger.
And the answer is
well, because genetic.
We know that height is
about 70% heritable.
And he didn't have the
genetics to get taller.
Like me, those questions
sort of stuck with him.
And as he started his
scientific career,
he started wondering
about the genetic bases
of these differences
in athletic ability.
He started a study
called "Heritage,"
which is sort of the key
study on genetic variation
as it applies to
athletic performance
and has been extracting data
from that for about 15 years.
It's one of these huge
population studies.
They took a huge group
of sedentary people,
put them on the same
training program,
and then measured how
much they progressed.
Your average person in
that 20-week program
has an improvement somewhere
between 15 and 25%.
And to be really
technical about it,
that's the increase in
their VO2 max, their ability
to process oxygen as
an endurance athlete.
So back to our 100
average woman USAs,
60% sit right in the
middle of that bell curve,
somewhere between 15%
and 25% improvement.
Those are your sort of
normal training responses.
Another 25% have
responses that are
a little further
out on the curve,
either below normal
or above normal,
but not terribly extreme.
So now we're down to
extreme responders,
and we're down to 15%.
We're down to 15 out of
our 100 average women.
7% to 8% of that
population will have
very low responses, like zero
improvement or 1% improvement.
Matter of fact,
some of these people
will show adverse responses.
Their cholesterol will go up.
Their blood pressure will go up.
We don't ever even really
consider that possibility.
But for some people,
exercise is not a benefit.
So now we're left with 7%
or 8% of the population,
again, with a high response
to aerobic endurance training.
So these are people, like 8%
of the population roughly,
I would argue, even
has a shot here
at reaching the elite level.
You can be a normal responder
and have a high baseline
and have a nice athletic career.
When you really look at
this sort of VO2 max values
that you need to have to compete
at the elite level-- which
are crazytown-- for women,
they tend to be in the 70s.
For men, they're in
the mid 80s to even
there's been some
90s, which are insane.
It's not even enough
to be a high responder.
It's not even enough to be
one of these eight people
because you need to also
have a high baseline.
If I start from a 40 and
can get a 30% increase,
I'm nowhere near
where I need to be.
I need to start at 50.
I need to start at 55, which is
already a pretty extreme value.
You can crunch the
numbers on that.
You get somewhere between 2%
and 3% of the population sort of
has that combination
of high baseline
plus high trainability.
It's a pretty small slice.
Before anything else happens.
Before you even have to
start to train or work or do
any of the things to actually
actualize any of this,
that's a pretty small
chunk of the population
that we're talking
about as given
the possibility of
this sort of success.
Richard Lewontin has this
great quote that I really like.
"Genes determine the
size of the bucket,
and environment is how
much is poured into it."
So for an athlete,
that environment
is work and practice
and opportunity.
Maybe I would have been, like,
a world-class soccer player.
I don't know.
I didn't really play soccer.
So it wasn't even an
opportunity for me.
This metaphor really
changed this summer
with the ice bucket stuff.
But I still like it.
Data has been a huge
theme, obviously.
Coming to Google and
talking about data
is a little intimidating.
It's really changed
sports, especially
in the past 10
years, I would say.
But I want to go way
back to the '20s.
This is the Western
Electric plant
in Cicero, Illinois, also
known as the Hawthorne Works.
And for those of you who have
done your social science stuff,
there were really famous
experiments done here
in the '20s and '30s,
sort of that dawn
of, like, scientific management.
There were 40,000 workers
at this plant every day.
And they were trying to
become more efficient.
How can we make them
make more stuff?
And so researchers
from Harvard came out
and started doing
research on productivity.
And one of the groups
they researched
was this group who made
telephone relay switches, which
were these big switches that
physically made your telephone
calls go where
they needed to go.
There's some controversy
about these studies,
like was the data good.
So bear with me, because it's
a little apocryphal here.
What they did is they started
to raise-- they're like, well,
if we put more light in here,
maybe they can see better.
Maybe the workers
can see better,
and they can make more switches.
And they turned up
the lights, and yeah.
And lo and behold, they
made more switches,
more relay switches.
And they're like, OK.
That's cool.
And they turned the lights
back down to the level
that they started at, and the
workers made more switches.
And they're like, OK.
Well that's weird.
What if we turn the lights down?
And they turned the
lights down a little bit,
and they made more switches.
And then they turned them back.
And so they do all these
environmental space.
Heat, cold, all of this.
Everything made them
more productive.
Which is the sort of thing
that scientific management
professors in the '20s
and '30s, were like, whoa.
And so they tried
to figure out why.
So here's where some
of the controversy is.
The Hawthorne
effect is typically
presented as the knowledge
that you are being observed,
being studied, causes you
to change your behavior.
I think that's actually
pretty compelling.
I don't know that these
studies actually prove that.
One explanation,
just as a side note,
is these weren't
workers who ever
got much feedback at the time.
Right.
And so they never really knew
how many switches they made.
And suddenly they had somebody
in a lab coat standing over
them, saying, hey.
You made 50 switches.
Or you made 60 switches.
Like, oh, cool.
Maybe I can make 65.
We've all experienced
that, right?
You give me an artificial
goal, I'll try and surpass it.
So it's possible that the
operators really got feedback,
and almost coaching in a
way they never had before.
Setting that aside, the idea
that we change our behavior
when we're tracking data
about ourselves, I think,
is kind of indisputable
at this point.
We've seen this boom in
wearables in the consumer
space.
How many of you have
played with these?
And you notice that, like, even
if it's as silly as like, oh.
I don't have 10,000
steps yet today,
and you're sort of marching
around your living room at 10
o'clock at night,
that's behavior change.
And behavior change
is really hard.
The science of behavior change
is filled with failed attempts
to get people to
change what they do.
It's a really compelling way to
start to change your behavior.
Now let's take that, put it
into an athletic context.
And I'm going to go back to
myself racing bikes in 1987.
So growing up in
western Pennsylvania,
there were no cycling coaches.
Believe me.
There was the guy at the bike
shop who was sort of my guru,
and there was a book called
"Bicycle Road Racing," written
by Eddie Borysewicz, who
had been the US Cycling Team
coach in 1984.
He was a Polish guy.
But one of Eddie's tips in that
book was if it was hot out,
you had your cycling cap on.
Because you didn't wear a helmet
because that wasn't a thing
that cyclists did then.
If it was hot out, you
could put a cabbage leaf
underneath your
cycling cap, just
like tour riders did
in the '20s and '30s.
We no longer carried our
spare tires looped like that,
although I think it's
a pretty awesome look.
That was the advice that
I got from the guy who
coached in the
Olympic team in 1984.
It's a cabbage leaf.
AUDIENCE: Did it help?
MARK MCCLUSKY: Um,
it kind of does.
Yeah, it kind of does help.
In the mid '70s, Polar,
the Finnish company,
created the first
heart rate monitor.
This isn't it.
This is the one that
came out in 1987.
They developed the first
wireless heart rate monitor
in 1977 for Finnish
cross country skiers
to help them in their training.
In 1987, they released
this model, the PE300.
I bought one of these.
I had a job.
And I took every cent
that I made in that job,
and I bought gear.
And nothing has changed.
The idea of training with
heart rate was crazy new.
And what this had,
the first-- this
was the first thing
that actually introduced
the idea of target
heart rate zones
to anyone outside of a
super-elite training program.
So you'd measure your
resting heart rate
and then sort of
like do some math.
It's like, well, if I'm training
here, I'm training really hard.
And if I'm training here,
I'm not training so hard.
So great.
I had that thing
strapped to my handlebars
and tried to divine
the information from it
with no coach or feedback.
Two nights ago, I did this ride.
So this is on a
Wahoo Kickr, which
is this really amazing
resistance trainer and trainer
road.
So this is the power
profile that I rode.
It's an easy ride because,
like I said, I'm out of shape.
This level of information
and data about my performance
and what I did would have
made my head probably explode
as a 17-year-old.
Right.
I'm just sort of like,
I just went and rode.
At the same time,
actually, Greg LeMond
and some of his
colleagues were starting
to do the first work on power.
One nice thing about
a bike and also rowing
is you can directly measure
the power that you output.
So I could do this ride
one day, and my heart rate
could be pretty low
because I felt great.
I could do this
ride another day,
my heart rate could be 20
beats higher because I'm sick
or I'm fighting an
infection or I'm not
recovered from my previous ride.
Heart rate's an OK way
to approximate this.
Power's an incredible
way to know
exact-- I produced 250
kilojoules of energy
in that ride, which
is not that much.
This ability to really get
into these things, this
is another example of it.
Zwift has actually
just launched this.
For the cyclists
in the room, this
is a massively multiplayer
virtual cycling game
that you can play with
your power trainer.
And you network
around the world.
Here's what's nuts.
Five pro teams,
like pro tour teams,
have talked about the fact
that their scouting people
in this game.
Because watts are watts.
Right?
The numbers don't lie.
If I could go out and put out,
famously, a little over 6 watts
a kilogram for an hour,
I have the physiology
to win the Tour de France or at
least be in the conversation.
So if it's some dude on a
trainer in Omaha, that's fine.
I know what he can do.
He might not be able to handle
a bike, and we can work on that.
But the physiology
is the tough part.
I just think it's
incredible that they're
scouting riders in this way.
The wearable for consumers
are well and good.
This is sort of the
professional version of it.
Catapult sports makes this.
It's called the OptimEye S5.
Catapult came out of a project
of the Australian Institute
of Sport, where they
were really looking
to track athletes' movement
in competitive settings.
So this little guy, this
is a British rugby player.
They tuck it in between
the shoulder blades there.
It's worn in lots of sort
of commonwealthy sports,
so Aussie rules football.
Rugby players wear it.
Tons of US teams have
started using it in practice.
It's not legal in games
yet in the United States.
And the people who are
least interested in having
it in competitive
settings right now
are the players, or specifically
the players' unions.
Because I know now, like,
say at contract time,
you know, like, yeah.
You were great last year, but
this year, your average sprint
acceleration's down a
meter and a half a second.
What's wrong?
Have you been staying
out too late at night?
Because I'm sort of tracking
your sleep now, too, or I'd
like to be.
I mean these concerns
about privacy
are a really
interesting subject.
Culturally, I think, we
have a very different stance
toward that than a lot
of other countries do.
This is commonplace.
So in Aussie rules
football, they actually
use it like real-time telemetry.
So I'm sure there are
lots of Aussie rules fans
watching and in the room.
It's kind of a weird,
interesting game.
One facet of it is you do
substitutions in real time.
Like the flow of the
game doesn't stop
and people run off and on.
And so they're getting
feeds from their players
onto an iPad showing things
like that acceleration rate.
And, like, if Jim
isn't accelerating
the way he did at the
start of the game, maybe
he's the player I should
be taking off for a rest
right now.
It's kind of like an F1 race
but with people and balls
and tackling one another.
One other thing about data.
This is Kirk Goldsberry.
I write about Kirk in the book,
and we did an excerpt in Wired
about him.
He's a cartographer.
He teaches at Harvard.
And he's also a crazy basketball
fan and basketball player.
And as he watched NBA games,
he thought to himself,
from his experience
as a player, I
have places on the court where
I'm really comfortable, where
I love taking shots.
And I have places on the court
where I'm not comfortable
and where I'm terrible
at taking shots.
And do NBA players
have that same thing?
So it's an interesting question.
The first trick in
answering that question
is finding the
data to answer it.
What Kirk ended up doing
is ESPN was running
shot charts on their box scores.
And he scraped all the data
from that quasi-legally-ish
and eventually was
able to map every shot
that every player in the NBA
took over a five-year span.
And then compare individual
players to that baseline,
and you get two things here.
So this is Dirk Nowitzki
of the Dallas Mavericks.
Size of the dot is how often
the player shoots from there.
The color from sort
of cool to warm
is how effective they are
from that area compared
to the average player.
So you see Dirk's a
great three-point shooter
from straight on.
He's an unbelievable
mid-range shooter,
especially from the
right side of the court.
He's actually the
best mid-range shooter
in basketball, which, is frankly
not a very efficient shot.
The style of the time right
now is to shoot three pointers
or try and be shooting layups
or close to the basket.
So he was able to extract that
from sort of rudimentary data.
At the same time,
there's a camera
right there at the
bottom of the screen.
And this is at the
United Center in Chicago.
Stats Inc., which
is this company that
provides statistical information
to most US pro leagues,
had acquired this technology
called Sport View.
It began as Israeli
missile defense technology
to try and optically
detect missile launches
and was adapted to sports, first
soccer and then basketball.
Because tracking everything
that happens on a basketball
court is hard.
So there are six cameras,
and it tracks the position
of everything on the court,
all the players, the ball,
the officials 25 times a second.
So you get basically
an x, y coordinate
for each of those things
25 times a second.
So with that kind of
data, you can go well
beyond just sort
of a shot chart.
You can ask different questions.
So here's the next
question Kirk answered.
This is the scoring
percentage that NBA players
have on average
close to the hoop.
This is the most
important territory
on the basketball
court to defend.
And you can see, like,
players are really successful
scoring there.
But when you swap in
different defenders, what
happens to people taking
shots in that area?
So any Warriors fans in
the house, David Lee,
who's been injured this year,
is a terrible interior defender.
I really like David
Lee as a player,
but this is not David
Lee's strong suit.
David Lee is a good
scorer and rebounder.
He does not perform
particularly well.
We'll see what his
next contract looks
like based on that information.
Scoring and rebounding
are actually
easier to find than defense.
Larry Sanders is an
incredible interior defender.
He signed a $44 million
dollar contract the summer
after Kirk published
this research.
With the Bucks, he scores,
like six points a game.
It's about his defense.
There's one other way to defend.
And that's to stop your opponent
from even taking a shot.
So this looks at what happens
when an opponent takes a shot.
You can crunch the same
numbers a different way.
What defender, by
his mere presence,
suppresses shooting rates?
And when you do that,
it was to Dwight Howard.
So he was a Laker at the time
that Kirk did this research.
Opponents shoot 9% fewer shots
when Howard is near the basket.
Like imagine if he
blocked 9% of shots.
It's the same effect.
Right?
It's the virtual blocked shot.
It's an incredible thing.
In the crowd that day,
when Kirk presented this
at the Sloan Sports
Analytics Conference at MIT--
Daryl Morey is the GM
of the Houston Rockets.
And later that summer,
he signed Dwight.
I cannot confirm nor deny that
it's exactly because of that,
but it certainly
would have held up,
because he does like seeing
this sort of shot blocking.
A couple more quick
things, and that
is the importance of
getting the basics right.
Atul Gawande.
in his book "Better"
talks about this a lot.
He talks about we're so
bad at doing the things
that we actually know work.
We're constantly
drawn to the new,
to the novelty of
a new discovery
and not just like basic
blocking and tackling.
Right?
So a couple of quick ones.
Eating well.
The most popular food
venue for Olympians
is that at the Olympic games.
Here's a picture Bobby Lee took.
Now, in fairness, this is right
after the closing ceremony.
So the line's a
little bit longer.
But McDonald's is a
huge worldwide sponsor
of the Olympics.
And every Olympiad, you read
about people who go and eat
like 55 Big Macs and
then, like, wonder
why they aren't
performing very well.
I think for most of us, diet
is a really fraught thing.
I think we look for these fads.
We look for these
quick fixes again.
And this is another place
where our individuality
is incredibly profound.
I have colleagues who've
lost a ton of weight
on low-carb, high-fat diets.
I should not be on a
low-carb, high-fat diet.
That's not how my body
processes nutrients.
Everybody's body does
things differently.
Phil Wagner is a sports
scientist down here in Menlo
Park and has a lab called
Sparta Performance Science.
His whole thing is just
trying to give athletes
a couple of things.
He's like, it's so hard to get.
I can't give them this
complicated regimen to follow.
So he's got two rules that he
asks his athletes to follow.
He wants them to eat
1 gram of protein
per pound of body weight a day.
And he wants them to have
eight fist-size servings
of vegetables.
It's like, look.
If they do that,
they've done, like,
80% of what I need them to do.
And given their travel demands
and the schedule on them,
that's hard enough sometimes.
Here's the other one,
and that's sleep more.
We have this incredibly
strange cultural bias
against sleep in
the United States.
We have this, like, faux
machismo about, like,
I only need four hours a
night, like that's somehow
an awesome thing.
This is the 2005
Stanford basketball team.
They weren't great.
They went 16 and 4 that year.
Sorry for any Stanford
alums in the room.
But Cheri Mah, who is a
researcher at the Stanford
Sleep Center, did a really
fascinating experiment
with these guys.
They volunteered to
study the effects
not of sleep deprivation
but of sleep extension.
So when they started
the study, they
reported that they slept
almost eight hours a night.
Actually, by using tools, they
discovered that they actually
slept about 6 and
2/3 hours a night.
So they measured their
baseline amount of sleep
and then did testing on them.
They tested them in
sprint performance,
doing a shuttle run,
shooting free throws,
shooting three pointers.
Then they asked every
player on the team
to sleep as much as
they possibly could,
do everything they
could to sleep more.
And they did.
They slept a lot more.
They slept 100
minutes a night more,
which is almost 8 1/2 hours
a night of actual sleep.
And they got better at playing
basketball because of that.
The sprint times went down.
This is out of 10 free throws.
They made 9% more free throws.
And out of 15
three-pointers, they
made an extra 1 and change.
You know, 9%
performance improvement
is the sort of thing you
usually get from doping.
You know?
So I'd encourage you to think of
sleep not as a necessary evil,
but as a performance enhancer.
And I'm completely
fascinated by sleep.
The only sustainable
advantage is to learn faster.
This is something Scott
Drawer, who worked at UK Sport,
said this to me.
And it comes out of
Shell, Royal Dutch Shell.
And actually, this
is Arie de Geus,
who ran the strategic planning
operation at Royal Dutch Shell
and really invented a lot of
the idea of scenario planning.
How do you come up with business
strategies for scenarios
that may or may not
occur in the future?
And that was his thought.
That anything you do,
your competition's
going to ape almost immediately.
So the trick is that you have
to be able to learn faster.
The way you get to
a moment like this
is to not be stuck in
your ways, to not get
stuck in your thinking,
and to challenge
all of your
assumptions constantly.
And, as I said,
that is exhausting.
It's brutal.
But that's what these guys face.
The joy and the torment they
face is that today's crazy,
new experiment is
tomorrow's baseline.
And you just have
to keep challenging
yourself to move forward.
So thanks for having me.
This is my website if
you want to go there.
RACHEL O'MEARA:
Who has a question?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks for coming to speak.
You mentioned that data
has been helping the sports
science explode in
the last 10 years.
Why do you think
this is happening now
as opposed to 20 years ago?
MARK MCCLUSKY: On the
data front especially,
it's the availability
of sensor technology.
Right?
It's the fact that all
of us in our pockets
have something that has a
gyroscope, an accelerometer,
a GPS.
Those things were really
specialized pieces
of equipment before smartphones.
I think the boom in
sensors and the way
that their price has just
plummeted really has opened up
that market, especially
for normal folks.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the picture about the camera
on the NBA court.
So does that mean that
it can automatically
analyze all the pictures,
who takes the shot, where
and those data available
right now for analysis?
MARK MCCLUSKY: Yeah.
So getting the whole data set,
you have to know somebody.
Probably somebody
here knows somebody.
The NBA actually publishes now
on their site, nba.com/stats,
they publish a lot of statistics
derived from that Sport View
data.
But before last
season, the league
paid to have it
installed in every arena.
It had only been in
about 15 before that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And are there
other sports do you
think like, camera-based
or image-processing
based technology can enable
more improvements in the sports?
MARK MCCLUSKY: So
I mean, a lot of it
is about baseball
has had Sportvision,
which is just down
the road here.
Does PITCHf/x and
FIELDf/x, which
tracks the movement of the ball
and the movement of players
on the court.
Tennis uses optical technology
to call in and out now.
So there's an
interesting, I think,
balance between sort
of physical sensors
and that sort of
image-based thing.
You know, outdoor sports,
it's much easier if I just
slap a GPS on you and trace
you in the accelerometer
and do it that way.
Indoor sports don't
have that luxury.
So they have some other things
they need to figure out.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
scouting cyclists
based on the Zwift
data, for example.
And you also talked
about genetics.
I have two kids, like five
years old and two years old.
Do you see a structured way
of scouting future athletes
when they are young or
when they are teenagers?
MARK MCCLUSKY: I mean,
that's sort of the thing
that everybody holds up,
is, like, someday there'll
be a genetic test you
can give your kid.
And, oh, little
Billy can be an x.
I'll never say never when it
comes to science like that.
But we're a long way from that.
Let me go back to height, right?
Height's a pretty simple
trait in terms of the outcome.
When you start to look at the
snips involved, when you look
at the actual genetic
variant on the genome that
seems to be associated with
that variance in height,
there's something on the
order of 300,000 snips.
So if something pretty
straightforward like height
has that huge a data
set that we have
to look at that influences
it, something that
seems much more
complicated to me,
not as a geneticist,
athletic ability,
I can't imagine
that we're talking
about fewer snips than
300,000 certainly.
So when people talk
about sports genes,
there have been genes
like ACE and actin
that seem to have
some association with
increased either sprint
ability or endurance ability.
But you can't draw a
line between a gene.
I think that was the sort
of dream of early genetics.
It's like, oh.
There's a gene for everything.
It's, like, well, actually,
there is a gene for everything.
But every gene is for
everything in some ways.
So what I think we'll see
structurally in sports
is a bigger effort
to match athletes
to sports based on
their physiology
and their morphology.
Like that sort of height
stuff that I talked about.
My dream of playing in
the NBA died the day
that I stopped growing
at 5' 11 and 3/4".
AUDIENCE: In terms of
the different sports
and different countries, how
does the technology evolve?
Is it like a specific country
that really drives something?
Or what sports are
leading in what way?
MARK MCCLUSKY: Yeah.
That's a great
question, I think.
Let me take the countries first.
Going even further
back, the Soviet bloc
in the '60s and '70s is,
frankly, where a lot of this
really got going.
In some ways that were really
amazing in terms of research
and in some ways that were
really horrific in terms
of what happened to athletes in
terms of state-sponsored doping
programs, when they were
told, take your vitamins,
and it was really testosterone,
which is an effective way
to be a better
athlete but to live
a really awful life eventually.
After that,
Australia really took
the lead in the '80s and
'90s and sort of the lead-up
to the Sydney Olympics.
Australia made a
huge investment.
They opened the
Australian Institute
of Sport, which has really
been a world leader here.
And that was really the
first place in the West
that brought together
raw scientific research
and an elite
athletic population.
Because doing this research
on a non-elite population
is meaningless in a lot of ways.
In the past two or
three Olympic cycles,
the UK has really
been ascendant.
Part of that is because they
launched the national lottery
in the UK, and a quarter of the
money from the national lottery
is given to UK Sport for high
performance sports funding
and research.
The US spends zero dollars
as a country on any of this.
The UK spends $400
million or so a year.
We're a growth market.
The USOC funds some of
this, but that's all
from corporate donations.
In terms of sports, I
think endurance sports
have traditionally
led a lot of this
because they're
easier to measure.
Just cycling, running,
rowing, cross country skiing.
And they're a little more
directly physiologically
determined.
There are other things,
but at a certain point,
the size of your engine and
your physiological ability
is really important.
Team sports are way behind.
Team sports in the US
are way, way behind,
but catching up very quickly.
AUDIENCE: So at the
end, you mentioned
about learning faster.
And that seems like
quite a compelling idea.
And I was curious to understand
if that's also something that
comes with a natural baseline
and a natural rate of growth
or improvement, or if
that is more learnable.
MARK MCCLUSKY: Is
learning learnable?
AUDIENCE: Or fast learning.
MARK MCCLUSKY: Yes I would
say probably a little.
I mean, the answer to
nature or nurture is both.
Right?
And so I think that
there are probably
people who have Carol Dweck's
talked a lot about growth
mindsets, and that's really
helpful in this context
because, again, you're
challenging your own ideas
constantly.
And it seems like
some people are
more inclined to that worldview.
I think you can
build organizations
that support it
particularly effectively.
I think we talk a lot
about some of that
here in the Valley on
fail-fast and iterate
and do all those things.
The trick in the
sporting world is
your outcomes are very clear.
And that's awesome
in a lot of ways.
Right?
It would be nice to know at
the end of the day, like,
did I win or lose?
I sit and I edit a story.
Like, am I awesome?
This seems OK.
But it's also hard,
because you can, I think,
lose focus on process and
get very outcome-focused.
So I think that's the tension
that the sports world faces
on that.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great.
Well, we'll close with that,
with a growth mindset mentality
and that we all need to
challenge our assumptions.
So thanks so much for
coming today, Mark.
MARK MCCLUSKY: Thank you.